I tweeted that because people think
they're born gay and I don't think
they're born gay the amount of
left-handed people back in the day was
really low because people with
left-handed were seen as inferior and
they were forced to use their right hand
more often but as it became more
acceptable then the amount of
left-handed people increased and it
became steady at what like 12 would you
say people choose to be left-handed
have to be attracted to women yes no I
wouldn't say so right
yeah I don't think I I I'm just
naturally attracted to women right
[Music]
I need to connect the dots or you got it
no he's too stupid he doesn't understand
hold on go ahead and collect my thoughts